la syrie mais je suis content d'être là
avec mieux d'une déclaration mois de
julien lepers il disait qu'il a avec un
écran via les faits il avait fait sa
pire émission oui non ça serait pire
souvenir d'ailleurs souvenirs
ces nectars
une émission c'était marrant tu avais
dit ça c'est fait un carton sur notre
mère
taseer car oui si si mais je compte sur
ta mère je taperai plus interviewé tous
mais c'est à l'époque où tout le monde a
peur les gars john chambers
nice la main non content rempli son
contrat en constante et 40 degrés à
l'ombre et ça c'est fini au pistolet à
eau sur la plage parce qu'ils ont ruiné
les missions pour nous ils vont tous à
vos moi je m'excuse héroïne non mais
c'était ça mais des fois on sait pas
s'arrêter ce fort du laguiole c'est
sympa que je vais d'abord d'arline
là tu peux être bon de borderline
d'achat ça va très très bien
at-elle déclaré que la
wii bon c'est à peine si vous vous
embrassiez avec julien a oui on voit se
dessécher d'accord ah oui
merci
de croo
c'est vrai ça calme c'est vrai que c'est
bien fait du bien une pousse
bo business c'est à dire il arrive on
s'embrouille et on fait des bisous deux
secondes après un
joli jardin pendant la séance en baisse
j'ai vu tomber de nouveau concept ouais
lardy b12 leur diplôme à la ferme c'est
vrai vous aussi vous étiez embrassé avec
guy bedos on s'est réconcilié avec
peabody on s'est réconciliés en déviant
du 21 avril quand le pen a failli être
président de la république en plus ce
sont les goûters nausées bout des lakers
n'avaient plus de sens
et là je vous ai toujours pas atteint
ouais on s'est appelé avant-hier
d'accord il va bien très bien il va
bientôt faire une scène à paris il va
très bien il tombera c'est toi c'est
vrai ouais il m'a dit eric je les adore
avez vous confiance
c'est très gentil on ne respecte pas ce
bon j'suis bien vous êtes prêts pour
finir son grand champion fazila oui mais
quelle est la date de naissance de
julien lepers
1949 le 12 août bonne réponse quel est
le vrai nom de julien lepers oh non ça
c'est ben vrai tout les barbares ces
deux paires ça ça c'est mon nom mais mon
vrai prénom c'est ronan quelle est
l'émission ou des buts julien lepers sur
france 2 le début au début le perche au
nom dans cet été les matins à 10 shows
de fêter les matins en quelle année
julien lepers a commencé la présentation
de questions pour un champion
88 10 bravo 88 ça fait 16 ans combien le
téléspectateur julien lepers a perdu
pendant la canicule de l'été 2003
et las non ça va ouais ouais ouais ça
c'est dur ça c'est franchement dur 6 mai
pas mal ça nous empêche pas des numéros
encore actuellement ça marche ce que
julien lepers fait exprès de se coiffer
comme ça si
c'est une question non c'est normal loi
je suis normal assez normal c'est pour
rappeler à batman oui non mais tout le
monde vous le dis j'imagine que voilà
michael c'est incroyable interview
michael keaton
non habitués on habite ici maintenant
non michael keaton comment sarah
interdit quand je suis content d'être là
amso pas le risque n'a rien vous parlez
français impeccable michael comment ça
se fait bah parce que j'ai passé mes
vacances en france
il ressemblait à julien lepers oui on me
le dit souvent oui je connais pas julien
lepers mais tout le monde me dit alors
ah comprends pas je sais pas qui c'est
que c'est qu'ils julien lepers bas c'est
un mec qui fait du porno en france
alors est-ce que julien est ce que c'est
vrai que vous avez eu l'idée du 4 à la
suite après avoir vu un porno oui quatre
à la suite ouais ouais ouais ouais ouais
effectivement depuis je me fais quatre à
la suite
est ce que c'est vrai que s'il france 3
rediffusait des vieilles émissions de
questions pour un champion personne ne
s'en apercevrait julien
c'est vrai je pas changé dans sa vie à
plus de cheveux avant c'était oui
j'avais un peu plus de choses donc vous
êtes ici pour un dvd avec des vidéos
assez nette est passée là où bébé d un
dvd i qui était un dvd interactif mais
ça c'est énorme ça voilà c'est le dvd
issa de dvd de question pour le champion
tubulaire et maison vous mettez à la
maison on joue comme dans le jeu jouer
en famille ou en live et c'est aussi
pour les ordis dans le jeu pc avec un cd
rom à 1380 question je sais pas si j'y
vois là et on peut jouer en réseau avec
des gens qui veulent
chez ce cas là dessus en plus j à la
première émission diffusée en 90
la première il ya 16 ans était la
première sur 4800 faire j'avais entendu
parler de ça est ce qu'il ya
quarante-cinq minutes de votre vie
dedans oui
assez apporté il ya tous les films x que
j'ai fait et avec panique dans mon slip
et toutes celles ça va et ça fait un
moment on sait plus très bien c'est bien
s'est
réjoui
questionnée
qu'elle se voir champion ce soir avec
jamel debbouze moi je joue pas je
regarde
avec
hervé gagner moi ouais ben
applaudissements je reprends avec erika
jamais
la glatt h à saint-pierre
pierre dissaux
bon allez vous commencer
recentrer les facile facile jusqu'à le
groupe anglais ses deux premiers
attention le premier qui donne la bonne
réponse qu'il a été chanceux
satisfaction en 65
hélas comme on n'avait
jamais vu cela moi série qui la magie
avec buzzer
comédienne quelle comédienne et
chanteuse est la partenaire de sonny
bono pour ipod touch and go away
aboubakar
est des joints conjugue les riches
payent je n'encaisse qui
licencient jamais regardé cette émission
pascal bour california to
the mamas and the papas se met à jouer
comme lcd ou chanteurs gilles avait
triché non je ne sais pas je veux dire
qu'il avait triché
je veux pas regarder il avait regardé
laquelle chanteurs noirs américains et
les lausannois on se dit que oui on se
serait dit bien joué
mais c'est blindtest chanteuse qui est
lauréate de l'eurovision 67 et myriam
non avec papa dame string la chanteuse
obtenu 110
chanel haye est là
jordan
m
non
ouais toujours que c'est plus marrant
dans les loges les banques non mais il
ya des gars laurent gerra
sèmassi ce temps des choix sont super
sympas et poussé mieux là bas qui arrive
aux [ __ ] le voit c'est sur la bouche
c'est un jugement c'est l'amour
john battelle peur
salut que jamais
attention et granby en ce concerne les
graphes ont chanté génial duo mis six
interprètes bicis robinson en 68 time
and garfunkel
gagés
nous sommes à l'abri c'est là qu'elle
chanteur américain le créateur de
nominal à 1,65 ennemis wilson pickett
on avait zéro alors là c'est plus dur
quelle est cette chanson quelle chanson
de carole king et gerry goffin rend
célèbre little et va en soit cet accord
alors non je vous pour de vrai alors là
celle-là c'est là les plus hauts sur la
musique n ont pas eu de la musique parce
que monsieur ouais voilà celle là tiens
non en 65 à quel chanteur doit-on la
reprise de guantanamera du groupe laisse
arrive à évoquer leurs noms avaient
belafonte il a chanté je pensais oui il
a chanté je pense j'ai gagné non non non
quel chanteur français on va dire
chanter en france je dis ça je ne
sais où tu gagnes dans l'émission je
n'ai jamais un titre claude françois
donne-t-il à la chanson mais to love des
everly boîte belles belles belles comme
le geig zack taylor
laurent
julien quel titre porte l'adaptation de
barbray mme hababa baril et maintenant
c'est moi je le dis ce que tu attends si
tu me la joues tu sais toi moi et pas de
problème
le groupe n'est pas big bags je suis à
modérer islam alors l'agressif 62
chanteuse française d'origine bulgare
qui reprend le site du lieutenant
laurent marchal
c'était un centre way
que ça mais on finit comme sarah et
celle là celle là pour l'arrêt pour la
route à la dernière lan en plus que
michael keaton nous ce soir
en 1961 déjà la date 61 quel chanteur
reçoit son premier disque d'or pour
viens danser le twist adapté de l'esm
ils se gagnent de chubby checker coeur
c'est johnny johnny hallyday
les amis
maintenant qui a écrit cette chanson
le faire mais ça
monsieur
un
des problèmes est un gardien non tu
déclarais en ce moment il ya une chose
qui me gâche la vie c'est mon contrôle
fiscal des fois ça frôle l'acharnement
tu en es où non mais je jouais ouais
c'est pas facile c'est à dire contrôle
fiscal s'est pas terminée mais bon ils
ont raison de dire qu'il faut le faire
qu'il faut payer ses cols on paye je
paye mais je vais pas payer plus que ce
que je dois c'est tout mais on en est là
et alors mais ça se règle ça serait
aussi en train de se régler en train de
sauver les banques ou de là on fait les
problèmes ce normal dans ces moments
j'ai choisi problème scientifique
la
carlier guy carlier qui a déclaré ce
mois-ci le forez gamme du paf alors
aujourd'hui sur france 3 térawattheures
parce que quand tu croises dans les
couloirs tu t'en fous dans le pays doit
fait la paix non sérieusement on a fait
la paix il ya cinq six mois sur des
patins télévision on sait pas que c'est
non mais j'ai promis de 2,2 de respecter
cette paix ouais je ne parle plus de lui
en mal il parle plus de moi en mal tout
va bien entre nous et on a fait la paix
en sem partners france il a du talent
car là je dis non non c'est vrai
j'ai entendu le tueur à cette heure là
c'est à france inter si c'est vrai oui
c'est vrai et je vous dis pas tu l'as
dis hein parce que j'ai envie de le dire
mais c'est vrai non c'est pas vrai si
c'est vrai je respecte bern le fou du
roi et il a balancé un truc c'était
dégueulasse comme quoi ça oui moi je me
dis qu'on va faire c'est à la main on
s'est embrassés on s'est dit plus jamais
ça va être moulé a bien roulé et passer
par le site ferme à saint louis c'est
moralement
le
oui oui non je voulais dire un mot parce
que il m'est arrivé un truc incroyable
ya pas longtemps je fais de la musique
sur scène en ce moment je tourne et
fantastique marche pas moins fantastique
ça marche très bien et je voulais dire
un petit mot là dessus si tu le permets
si vous le permettez les producteurs
doivent alors qu'est ce qui s'appelle
royal passée genre quel sera mon
t'appeler ce qui fait écouter
[Musique]
sa pétoire ouais bah julien lepers
c'est un peu une musique une porno mais
oui cela s'appelle musset qu'érotique on
a bien servi de buggy pour ya dix ans
c'est à moi ce jeu qu'est ce que je me
suis les branches sur cette chanson
je recommence trois cas
laisse-moi par des deux satellites parce
que j'ai un truc qui m'a risques et non
pas parce que je me dois je suis branlée
sur cette chance
pour que je viens de jouer du piano
d'andorre dans le spectacle et pour que
je vienne animer le truc et on est parti
en tournée depuis trois semaines ça
marche très bien les valses de vienne
les chansons du vieux paris et je me
mets au piano non je joue
tu as vu ce qu'il apporte aux jeunes
mais
c'est faux
c'est la mi temps
c'est bon
merci tirer
en sourire elle est bien sûr verra même
cher notre sourire cherchent-ils de
cheikh tidiane faye locke ma nature je
devienne keira dans la chambre
il est tombé du secteur en dévoilant des
capotes la côte
je deviens une caméra dans les champs
bon attention peut-être qu'ils vont
participer à une émission de télévision
bonsoir
[Musique]
non pas là
julien lepers dames messieurs
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
a l'habitude abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu